it's time for cruise news your daily
trip to the good news castle with me at
the desk two good news nights and
shining armor our favorite young
reporter emmy
i'm eaton excited to be here
and
my other trusted co-pilot rusty russ
matthews yeah
hi hi everybody
i feel the exact same way as emmy i'm so
excited to be here all right let's get
right into it first up we're going to
atlanta to meet three tiny wieners
living in big style
newsweek reports a man named benjamin
mazur is racking up millions of views
for his mini living room for his mini
wiener dogs no you guys literally this
is all to scale it's the cutest thing
ever all the details tiny lamps teeny
tiny teeny tables a tiny flat screen and
there is art hung at wiener dog eye
level oh
come on um and the coffee table is
actually a salad bowl and the couches
are perfect height to protect their
little spines
um i mean what do you think about this
story emmy i mean i just love dogs
because um
my dad he won't let us get a
you guys out here dog i should get a dog
hello
what kind of dog would you want to get
you think golden noodle a golden turtle
what would you name your dog if you got
one uh well
our neighbor has a dog named amber so we
could name it like sapphire or something
and they could be like the two gem twins
i'm sold
i'm sold too don't kill me okay
all right ross your story all right well
emmy we're going to go to your home
state now for some good news you ready
yes okay well this comes from the east
idaho news last december the olsen
family was struggling to make ends meet
and when the mom timonie olson posted a
pic to facebook of her ugly sweater
cookies well some people reached out to
her they wanted to order some and
timoney thought why not and then her
secret talent blossomed the customer
order started pouring in and today she's
got her own business called cookie
monster and she's booked out six weeks
in advance
you cannot get these cookies
and she says
this business has taken off and has
changed her whole family's world and i
know you've tried her cookies right yeah
she made my uh birthday cookies they are
we're just like so cute and
today i
have a special delivery for you guys no
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Applause]
there is a drew's news there's an olive
and a frankie a flower love the way you
look
i have to just say uh to timoney um at
who is the cookie monster first of all
everything you're doing timony is so
clever the name is very clever
how is that not taken already brilliant
um and then the cookies you make i
looked at each and every slide of her
cookies they're you're really you've got
the goods and timing we're going to
feature you on our small business gift
guide you are just doing extraordinary
things and you are really so special
thank you so much awesome for bringing
this to our attention
[Music]